Varys: Aegon landed at the mouth of the Blackwater
River and raised a primitive Aegonfort in
the disputed lands between Harren's and Argilac's
kingdom so that neither could decide whose
problem he was.
Adopting the customs of the Seven Kingdoms,
Aegon unfurled his own banner with a red three-headed
dragon breathing fire upon a black field.
Visenya crowned him with a ruby-studded circlet
of Valyrian steel while Rhaenys hailed him
as the first high king the continent had seen
since the Dawn Age.
As his lords and the gathered locals cheered
him, Aegon named his loyal friends to a small
council led by Orys Baratheon, whom he called
"my strong right hand."
The title stuck, and he became the first Hand
of the King.
But for now, Aegon's kingdom contained only
a rocky island and a handful of fields.
The other kings had large armies, ships, castles,
and thousands of years of rule.
But Aegon had dragons.
He had chosen for the words of his house,
"Fire and Blood."
Before he was done, the rivers, fields, and
skies would turn red.
Viserys Targaryen: Soon after his coronation,
Aegon returned to the mouth of the Blackwater
River, where he had first set foot on Westeros.
A small town had since sprouted around his
primitive fort.
To honor their new master, the locals dubbed
it "King's Landing," though it looked more
fit for a hedge knight, with wooden palisades,
muddy streets, and piles of mangled swords
carted in from every corner of the conquest.
But when Aegon made it his court, wood became
stone, black mud was buried beneath a Red
Keep, and the collected swords of Aegon's
foes were blasted by dragon fire and became
a seat fit for the Conqueror and the greatest
dynasty this world has ever known.
House Targaryen.
Varys: King's Landing is both a city and a
curse.
Aegon the Conqueror was the first king to
land there.
His first conquest, a tiny village at the
mouth of the Blackwater River, where he raised
a wooden fort.
When it became clear that Aegon would earn
his title, people flocked to the fort and
renamed it "King's Landing" in his honor.
The ploy succeeded, and Aegon chose King's
Landing for his capital over older and more
beautiful cities like Oldtown and anywhere
else.
The currying of royal favor thus became the
foundation of the city, and blood its bricks.
Maegor the Cruel, Aegon's son, completed the
city's famous Red Keep to hold the trappings
of power: the royal family, the Kingsguard,
and the Iron Throne.
To maintain the new castle's secrets, Maegor
murdered all its masons and craftsmen at a
feast, which he catered with the new castle
servants, who soon found all its secrets for
himself.
When the Faith Militant challenged his rule,
Maegor razed their Sept of Remembrance to
the ground with them inside at prayer and
erected the Dragonpit on the ashes.
Petyr Baelish: Prince Maegor, a warrior who
was proud and arrogant.
Maegor agreed to marry the High Septon's niece
to unite the Faith and the Crown, but then
secretly wed a second wife in a Valyrian ceremony
artfully combining bigamy and heresy.
When word of it got out, the King was forced
to exile Maegor and choose a septon as his
new Hand.
But the damage had been done.
The King had trusted in family, and his brother
had set off a rebellion that would claim his
rule and his life.
The High Sparrow:When Aegon's heir wed his
daughter to his son, the Faith could brook
such abomination no longer.
The High Septon led the denunciation of the
Targaryens.
And all over Westeros, the Faith Militant
took up their swords against the dynasty and
its supporters.
The Faith Militant set upon and punished the
septon who had performed the ceremony.
A few of the Faith Militant's more militant
members even scaled the walls of the castle
and would have slain the king and his family,
had a knight of the Kingsguard not intervened.
Frightened, the king fled to Dragonstone,
where he soon died of cramps.
And so ascended the king's younger brother,
Maegor the Cruel.
His first act was to challenge the Faith Militant
to kill him if they believed his rule to be
ungodly.
To the order's eternal credit, they accepted.
Ser Damon Morrigen proposed a "trial by seven,"
Ser Damon and six of the Faith Militant against
the king and his six champions.
It was a contest in which the kingdom itself
was at stake, and the accounts and tales are
many.
But at the end of it, Maegor alone lived,
proving that the throne was rightfully his.
He mounted the black dragon, Balerion, and
burned down the sept in King's Landing while
the Faith Militant were inside at morning
prayers.
The screams of the burning and dying men were
said to echo throughout the city.
Though Maegor had won the trial by seven,
he demanded the complete destruction of the
Faith Militant and the Faith itself, if necessary.
He made war upon the order wherever he found
it.
Yet the Faith Militant would not surrender,
raising armies of their own and turning Maegor's
own lords against him.
The Father's justice may not always be swift,
but it is certain.
One morning, Maegor was found dead on the
Iron Throne.
No one knows how.
Maegor's cruelty died with him.
His successor saw the wisdom of a united crown
and faith, and his Hand reached an accord
with the High Septon.
As long as the Iron Throne defended the Faith,
the Faith would put aside its own swords and
its condemnation of the Targaryens.
Viserys Targaryen:The Dance began, as
many dances do, with an old man and a young
girl.
The queen had failed to produce a son for
her king, so he anointed his daughter, the
Princess Rhaenyra, as his heir.
But years later, the king remarried, and his
new wife, Queen Alicent of House Hightower,
gave him a son.
Feeble and foolish, the old king refused to
change the succession.
He didn't even see how his court had split
into two rival camps of Blacks and Greens,
after the dresses that the princess and the
queen had worn to some tourney.
One night, a servant found the old king had
died in his sleep and ran to inform Queen
Alicent.
Protocol dictated that the bells would be
rung and a raven sent to Dragonstone to summon
the heir, Princess Rhaenyra, for her coronation.
But Alicent had other plans.
None were more surprised to hear of Prince
Aegon's succession than Prince Aegon himself.
At first, the fool rejected the crown, but
his mother pointed out that his sister Rhaenyra
would return such loyalty by taking his head.
As the old king's trueborn son, he'd always
be a threat.
Aegon relented.
He was crowned in the Dragonpit, and his wife
and sister Helaena became queen.
His brother Aemond flew off to win over the
few great lords whose support Aegon didn't
already have.
The banner of the gold dragon flew over King's
Landing and the Red Keep as Aegon, Second
of His Name, ascended the Iron Throne.
He would not sit it long.
Robert Baratheon: One day King's Landing looked
up and saw two dragons circling their foul
city.
Daemon and Rhaenyra had come for her throne,
for the city was defenseless.
Aemond had taken the king's army from the
city, and worse, he'd taken his dragon Vhagar.
Seeing that resistance was hopeless, the small
council surrendered the city, the Queen Mother
Alicent, and the broken Queen Helaena.
But not King Aegon.
Somehow, despite his wounds and delirium,
he had vanished from the city.
And so Queen Rhaenyra climbed the steps and
seated herself of the Iron Throne.
Legend has it that as she left that hall later,
blood trickled down her legs and hands, proving
the Iron Throne had spurned her.
Nonsense!
It's a chair made of steel blades.
Rhaenyra had wanted it all her life and had
sacrificed two sons for it.
She likely gripped the damn thing too tight.
Shireen Baratheon: When Rhaenyra's last son
wed Aegon's only daughter, the Dance of Dragons
officially ended.
Ash and burned men.
All that was left of the Riverlands.
Two scared children spouting oaths they didn't
understand.
All that was left of the mighty House Targaryen.
Ancient skulls and hatchlings that grew no
bigger than cats.
All that was left of the dragons.
The High Sparrow: To steward his monument
to vanity, Baelor summoned the High Septon
of the Faith from his ancient seat in Oldtown
and gifted him with ornate robes and a crown
of crystal and gold.
And like a fool, the High Septon put on his
lord's motley and danced at his lord's table,
and with each passing year, the High Septons
fell ever lower.
How can the flock be kept safe from wolves
when the shepherd sleeps in their den?
Baelor himself appointed a simple-minded stonemason,
believing him the Smith reborn.
And when he died, Baelor replaced him with
an eight-year-old boy whom Baelor had seen
speaking with doves that answered with the
voices of the Seven.
Still, the common people revere Baelor as
the Blessed.
They tell of how he forced a high lord to
wash a beggar's feet, fasted to tame his unnatural
lusts and walked the Boneway himself to make
peace with Dorne.
Many septons and septas even claim that Baelor
rescued his cousin, the Dragonknight, from
a snake pit because no viper would strike
a man so pure and holy.
A lie!
Baelor was bitten a dozen times and was bedridden
for half a year, and yet he didn't die.
Petyr Baelish: When the last dragon died,
it was only a matter of time before the Targaryens
followed.
Varys: By "only," you mean another century?
Baelish: Which they wasted trying to replace
their lost advantage: incinerating their own
palaces to hatch dragon eggs, drinking wildfire
to become dragons, and, let's not forget the
Mad King's favorite, burning men alive so
he could pretend to be a dragon.
Jaime Lannister: Kingslayer.
A word every man and woman in Westeros spits
at me, though many can't name the king I slayed.
I understand.
To them, I'm a symbol of everything they'll
never have and a warning that'll never apply.
So they can loathe me from the safety of their
small lives.
But when a dog goes mad, we put it down.
Why not a king?
I served at the king's pleasure as he burned
Rickard Stark alive and strangled his son,
inciting the rebellion.
I defended the king's honor against courtiers
as his generals lost battle after battle with
Robert.
I kept the king's secrets when his pyromancers
hid caches of wildfire beneath King's Landing.
I gave the king counsel when my father's army
was at the city gate, and Grand Maester Pycelle
lied that my father had come to save him.
Many forget that I also tried to defend the
king from harm.
When the Lannister soldiers poured through
the gates, it fell to me to hold the Red Keep
as the only Kingsguard in the city.
I knew we were lost and sent to Aerys, asking
his leave to make terms.
My man came back with the royal command.
"Bring me your father's head if you are no
traitor."
Aerys would have no yielding.
His pyromancer was with him, my messenger
said.
I knew what that meant.
Aerys Targaryen was alone in his throne room
when I found him, picking at his scabbed and
bleeding hands.
The fool was always cutting himself on the
Iron Throne.
"Burn them!
Burn them!" he kept muttering.
Aerys had decided to let Robert be king, after
all, over the charred bones and ashes of King's
Landing.
He must have thought his pyromancer was near
enough to obey him, but I'd killed him a few
minutes before in the courtyard.
As I approached the throne, sanity flashed
behind the King's eyes for a moment, just
long enough to read the look in mine.
His eyes grew huge, and the royal mouth drooped
open in shock.
He turned and ran.
A single thrust was all it took to end the
greatest dynasty the world had ever seen.
Beneath the empty eyes of the dead dragons
on the walls, the last dragon king squealed
like a pig and shat himself.
So easy, I thought.
A king should die harder than this.